hallo kamera da oben so bestimmt
willkommen bei philo cast wir sind bei
einer neuen folge das letzte mal haben
wir nicht so viel zeit wir haben
ziemlich angeheizt über den klimawandel
gesprochen so dass uns am ende fast die
luft ausgehen
der fast repräsentiert sie für
klimawandel selbst interview der das
waren wir heute nicht heute hatten wir
mal klima halt mir völlig raus obwohl es
ein so ein tag ist wo man morgens
nachrichten nachrichten gelesen hat dass
im wirtschaftsministerium ein gesetz
momentan kursiert wonach der abstand
zwischen windrädern und häusern immer
mehr als 1000 meter sein muss das wird
die windkraft in deutschland mehr oder
weniger gegen null fahren also wenn du
mich jetzt interview zu interview ist
ein leicht verzweifelten und gott nein
aber es schön dass du da bist danke dass
du dir die zeit nimmst
heute haben wir ein bisschen mehr zeit
genommen und jetzt sozusagen das große
thema ist die symbiose von physik und
philosophie und da die allererste frage
bevor wir dann zu konkreten beispielen
kommen die möchten wir nämlich auch
besprechen damit unsere zuschauer auf
zusagen vom was handfestes haben erstmal
sowie fragen nach der symbiose selbst
glaubst du es ist notwendig dass physik
und philosophie an symbiose miteinander
haben wenn sie denn überhaupt eine haben
oder ist es ja zum beispiel auch in
deiner tätigkeit als als professor er
aus lust und laune heraus dass diese
disziplinen miteinander kombiniert also
erstmal ist es so dass mal dass ich als
student erfahren habe wie unglaublich
wichtig ist also für mich war physik zu
studieren und philosophie dazu zu hören
also der satz von bahnhof kann den
schalter in naturphilosophie da ging es
eben darum ich sage ihnen jetzt mal
warum sie für physik studieren also es
ging dann tatsächlich darum von der
philosophischen perspektive aus auf
dieses ganze fach zu schauen und
praktisch mit dem instrumentarium der
philosophie auf die für sich zu gucken
nämlich zu gucken
inwiefern sind denn die aussagen die
dort gemacht werden widerspruchsfrei wie
ist die konsistenz diese aussagen wie
gewinnen die überhaupt erkenntnis diese
physiker und welches metaphysische
weltbild haben sie haben sie überhaupt
ein weltbild oder machen sie nur einfach
irgendwas und es war einfach für uns
studenten glaube ich schon ziemlich
wichtig dass da jemand war der ganz
liebevoll kann entscheider war ja selber
physiker ganz liebevoll seine eigene
wissenschaft betrachtet hat sowie heißt
es im italienischen so schön con amore
aber immer auch mit einer gewissen
distanz zuguckt hat was macht eigentlich
für sich so erfolgreich
wo sind die grenzen davon und in diesem
sinne versuche ich eben auch philosophie
zu unterrichten für alle diejenigen die
aus ihren jeweiligen wissenschaften
kommen und etwas brauchen womit sie ihre
wissenschaft aus einer perspektive
anschauen können die selber nicht in
dieser wissenschaft drin ist aber
trotzdem sich nach wissenschaftlichen
kriterien unterwirft also philosophie
ist ja nicht ein irgendwie ich mache da
mal irgendwas sondern es gibt ja sehr
wohl
ganz klar es klare kriterien von
philosophischen hypothek für
philosophische hypothesen genau wie es
für empirische prothesen solche
kriterien gibt und deswegen in diesem
hinten in diesem hinblick glaube ich
dass philosophie und physik unbedingt
etwas miteinander zu tun haben
ich weiß nicht ob es eine symbiose ist
aber ich glaube das ist wichtig ist dass
sie immer so nah wie möglich bei
einander sind auf der einen seite damit
diejenigen die philosophie betreiben
wissen was ist in den wissenschaften los
was wird da gerade als tatsache
gehandelt und auf der anderen seite dass
diejenigen die diese forschung betreiben
auch eben das nicht im luftleeren raum
tun sondern sehr wohl in den
geistesgeschichtlichen historischen
ethischen erkenntnistheoretischen
wissenschafts theoretischen ramthun und
damit auch erkennen was sind eigentlich
die grenzen unserer unserer behandlung
und bei einer sache ich würde sogar noch
ein bisschen stärker darauf dringen dass
zum beispiel ingenieurwissenschaften
viel stärker mit philosophie in kontakt
kommen
um genau das zu machen was für die
physik schon so lange normal ist also
für die philosophen die physiker
untersuchen schon normal ist nämlich
warum ist das eigentlich so erfolgreich
und wir haben das bei dieser
grundlagenforschung da haben wir schon
lange gemacht aber warum funktioniert
technik eigentlich so gut also es gibt
ja inzwischen schon ein bisschen technik
philosophie aber angesichts der der
stärke und der gut dass und der
invasiven technisierung in unseren
alltag haben wir eigentlich viel zu
wenig philosophische betrachtungen wir
kriegen jetzt wieder ein ganz neues
aufgabenfeld mit künstlicher intelligenz
das bedeutet aber auch eine gewisse
technologie anzuwenden das heißt im
grunde braucht man heute mehr
philosophie denn je und zwar in einem
ganz angewandten erstmal ganz
angewandten sinne zu gucken mit welchen
konzepten aus der philosophie kann man
diese wissenschaften betrachten kann man
den wissenschaften auch helfen dadurch
dass man sie ein bisschen kritisch
betrachtet so ein bisschen
ich vergleiche das immer gerne damit
dass ein theaterkritiker ja durchaus
denjenigen die auf der bühne sind ein
bisschen sagen kann
das war jetzt nicht so gut oder da gibt
es vielleicht noch bedarf der
verbesserung wobei ist natürlich wobei
jeder schauspieler natürlich sagen lässt
doch keine kritiken was natürlich nicht
stimmt also in diesem sinne glaube ich
wäre dann eine größere nähe auch
publizistischen kommunikativen ehen
zwischen philosophie und vielen anderen
wissenschaften wäre dringend nötig unter
uns gesagt wissen wir unter uns
philosophie ist eigentlich viel zu
abgeschlossen viel zu hermetisch
abgeschlossen dann müsste viel mehr raus
es müsste viel mehr austausch geben und
ich glaube aber weil du das ja auch
angesprochen hast dass das konzept der
oder was heißt konzept freunde zu haben
die philosophen sind tut allen guten
philosophie natürlich auch ja ja ja
danke dass es gibt natürlich dass viele
punkte sozusagen vielleicht zum
allerersten das so wissenschaftstheorie
und erkenntnistheorie werden so
bereichen die sind diese in die world
sinnvoll sie ist in den wissenschaften
ja ja klar
na und und und ist jetzt aber so dass
zum beispiel in den neueren bereichen
also nicht für sich sondern in mechanik
ist es nicht so machen die das schon
oder ist es gerade die normative
aussagen vorschlag
ja es gibt ein paar bücher zum beispiel
klaus kornwachs hat zwei bücher
geschrieben philosophie für ingenieure
oder technik philosophie
dann gibt es in gernot böhme in
darmstadt der hat invasive technisierung
geschrieben und es gibt natürlich so
kulturphilosophen günther anders die die
antiquiertheit der welt geschrieben aber
selbst heute gar keine technik
philosophie beschrieben ganz wichtig
ganz wichtige arbeit
aber das ist ja wie soll ich das sagen
das ist was also in was müsste konkreter
werden also das müsste konkret wenn es
darum geht zum beispiel es gibt viele
veranstaltungen einsatz von technik von
digitaler technik und künstliche
intelligenz aber da werden meistens
immer eine wirtschaftsleute eingeladen
ab und zuwendung bauingenieure
eingeladen aber dass da mal philosophen
rein kommen und sagen jetzt überlegen
wir doch mal was hat denn das eigentlich
für konsequenzen ich habe zum beispiel
über den risiko begriff einmal einen
vortrag gehalten risiko als eine zukunft
die nicht eintreten soll
und was bedeutet es eigentlich wenn wir
immer mehr von diesen algorithmen
einsetzen die lernen wären sie benutzt
werden oder werden sie sich selber
benutzen
und wenn die jetzt ein urteil fällen was
heißt das wenn die ein urteil fällen
und dieses urteil war möglicherweise
falsch in einem rechtsstaat ist ein
jemand deren urteil fällt eine
entscheidung trifft eine handlung
vollzieht voll rechtsfähig wenn er über
über 18 uhr über 21 ist das heißt er
kann auch bestraft werden aber jetzt mal
unter uns gesagt mein computer ärgert
sich nicht oder freut sich noch nicht
mal wenn er im schacht gewinnt wie sehr
ich ihn dann bestrafen also auf auf
welcher ebene soll ich denn überhaupt da
irgendwas vollziehen wenn ich
algorithmen das überlasse das heißt mit
anderen worten ich muss jemanden haben
der unterschreibt dass die entscheidung
des algorithmus korrekt sind und gerade
für institutionen die sich mit dem thema
risiko beschäftigen also
versicherungsgesellschaften was fast
versichern die denn eigentlich wenn ein
wenn ein algorithmus sich pausenlos
verändert während während er in
anwendung sich befindet sich den vom
montag oder dem vom freitag
es kann ja sein dass der am freitag viel
schlechter ist als die variante am
montag
und daran sieht man dass also diese
auseinandersetzung was ist ein urteil
was ist eine handlungsebene also all
diese dinge die aus der ethik kommen die
in der rechtsphilosophie eine rolle
spielen
die müsste man mal wirklich mal
grundlegend für viele
nicht erklären wie gehabt vollmann das
immer gesagt hat philosophie es auch ein
klärwerk da werden erstmal mit griffe
geklärt wo von spreche ich denn
eigentlich und auch schon mal probleme
angepackt die vielleicht noch gar nicht
auftreten von denen wir aber wissen dass
sie uns irgendwann betreffen können also
ein bisschen prophylaktische wieder so
viel zu betreiben um lösungen anzubieten
für den fall der fälle
und ich glaube da ist noch viel zu tun
es werden überall werden zentren für ki
eröffnet an der tu gibt es jetzt ein
zentrum für künstliche intelligenz und
ethische fragen
aber die werden das wird von facebook
finanziert ich glaube ich weiß ich nicht
ob das jetzt unbedingt die richtige
verbindung ist wäre mir lieber der
freistaat würde das finanzieren anstatt
dass ein soziales netzwerk beginnt
praktisch ja leute zu finanzieren damit
die darüber nachdenken welche ethischen
konsequenzen der einsatz von kariert
würde ich doch sagen sollte man lieber
anders finanzieren sollte öffentlich
rechtlich seien und nicht von
irgendwelchen firmen finanziert werden
da weiß man nie also ich will ja niemals
unterstellen aber das werden wir nicht
so ist mir nicht geheuer
also ich denke dass wir sollten genügend
geld haben um wenn uns wenn wir sagen
das thema k s fielen unsere gesellschaft
so wichtig dann müssen wir das selber
machen hat selbstverständlich da
verständlich und ereignis
naturwissenschaften die frage wenn wir
von tragödien ja so als als epischen
titel für das gas stammt nämlich von der
von churchill greifen treasury ist ein
band seiner geschichte des zweiten
weltkriegs yahya antwort auf unsere
frage wäre das so zu sagen weil sieg und
niederlage was auch anders übersetzt
sein könnte mit grenzen möglichkeiten
hier und jetzt ist sozusagen meine frage
hat es eher den anschein dass das so zu
sagen wir haben jetzt ist
das verhältnis so ein bisschen noch in
klammern gesetzt ist es vielleicht so
dass die philosophie möglichkeiten haben
die physik an grenzen kommt und
umgekehrt
es ist erst mal so das glaube ich viele
die physik betreiben sich gar nicht für
philosophie interessieren die machen sie
wollen für sieg machen
die wollen was messen die wollen
experimente durchführen die wollen die
präzision ihrer experimente erhöhen also
die genauigkeit mit dem etwas messen
kann
die zeitskalen kleiner machen und so
weiter und so weiter und die
interessieren sich überhaupt nicht dafür
warum das so ist
also diese frage schon zu stellen wieso
ist eigentlich dieses verfahren ist ja
schon philosophie damit ist man schon
über die grenze der empirischen
forschung hinaus und betrachtet jetzt
von einer anderen ebene aus das ganze
also jede art von grenzüberschreitung
über das methodische hinaus gehört für
mich automatisch schon nicht mehr zu der
wissenschaftler zu sondern eben zu der
wissenschaft die sich mit den
denkstrukturen beschäftigen nämlich in
struktur wissenschaften und dem
philosophie ist nun mal eine struktur
wissenschaft was insofern denke ich dass
die frage nach dem nach den begrenzungen
mag sicherlich mal den einen oder die
andere geben die dann im laufe ihrer
tätigkeiten mal darüber nachdenkt
sondern wie weit kann man denn da
eigentlich gehen aber das mal von außen
zu betrachten hegel hat gesagt werden
die grenzen erkannt hat er hat sich
schon überschritten und zb gerade wenn
es um den wunderbares beispiel ich habs
gerade finden in der vorlesung auch
angesprochen
ich hab ja hier die vorlesung geschichte
der natur und die geschichte der natur
nie beginnt natürlich am anfang so und
mit diesem anfang gibt es die größten
herausforderungen aristoteles hatten
unbewegten erst bewege bei anderen war
scott und und alle alle möglichen
anfänge weil man da rein logisch eben
nicht auf nichts kommen konnte was eine
ursache die selber keine ursache hat
oder wie es so schön heißt in der
kosmologie manchmal der tag ohne gestern
also alles hat er angefangen zeit und
raum und so weiter und es gibt es eben
das schöne verfahren
man kann sich innerhalb der physik und
gucken welche grenzen gibt es denn da so
und einer davon max planck hatte mehr
1900 tatsächlich so was mal angegeben
hat aber noch gar nicht geahnt dass es
eine grenze ist
und dann kann man nochmal 100 jahre
zurückgehen lang hat im jahr 1900
geschrieben wir gehen zurück in die in
die erste kritische schrift von von
immanuel kant und stellen dann fest wenn
wir die kategorie die kausalität an
erster stelle stellen das heißt wir
wollen empirische wissenschaft machen
dass eine philosophische forderung wir
wollen im pirin machen also erfahrungen
wollen messungen machen wollen
unterscheiden können zwischen ursache
und wirkung zumindest in diesem app
systemischen sinne nicht unbedingt den
metaphysischen dann müssen wir
unterscheiden können zwischen ursache
und wirkung in einem messbaren sinne und
dann kann man tatsächlich den anfang des
universums praktisch auf kausal
sinnvolle kleinste längen kleinste
zeitskalen und so weiterbringen und du
beginnst ganz automatisch praktisch
wissenschaftliche inhalte philosophisch
zu interpretieren
das heißt du hast 300 will konstant da
gibt's gravitations konstantes branche
wirkungs quantum und die
lichtgeschwindigkeit dann wird ein
bisschen gemischt und dann hat siehe da
die kleinste kausal sinnvolle länge im
universum und damit die kleinste kausal
sinnvolle längen einheit für das
universum sind zehn hoch minus 35 meter
also hier wird es ganz konkret 20 größen
auch noch ganz eng und auch ganz konkret
war das ist eine klare zahl die hängt
mit den werten dieser naturkonstanten
zusammen und das sind 20 größenordnungen
kleiner als ein proton und das ist schon
klein und dann kann man das noch mal
durch die lichtgeschwindigkeit teilen
dann sieht man die kleinste kausal
sinnvolle zeiteinheit im universum sind
5 mal 10 hoch minus 44 sekunden sagt
einen nix aber immerhin
man kann aus all diesen ganzen
berechnungen dann sogar die anfangs m
also die die anfangs temperatur den
anfangs energie des universums
ausrichten das sind 10 hoch 32 kelvin
eine unglaublich hohe temperatur und
danach wird das universum aber nur noch
kälter weil wir wissen heute dass
universum expandiert und es wird dabei
immer kühler und das ist das tolle dass
man eben durch die anwendung für die so
philosophischer prinzipien auf eine so
physikalische frage was ist der beginn
ganz so praktisch seine ganzen probleme
von links otto gott oh gott wenn das
gegen null geht also wenn irgendwas
gegen null geht oder gegen unendlich
dann bricht das universum eigentlich
zusammen
mit kant mit kant und heisenberg
sozusagen mit mit max planck werner
heisenberg und immanuel kant ist der
anfang des universums safe gute frage
was ist wenn ich jetzt erste konkrete
punkt zudem bekommen könnten die frage
nach dem ursprung und das ist ja neben
äußerst philosophische fragen in erster
linie freigesprochen wurde alles tot ist
zum beispiel seiner metaphysik geht
darauf auch ein und er hat diesen tollen
bewegten bewegung nennt das heißt die
frage und dann warum sitzen wir hier
überhaupt irgendwas passiert was uns
hierher gebracht hatte dann allerdings
das zustande gekommen ist man sehr
schnell bei einer kette um die kette
führt irgendwohin
wir haben auch dass händler ein problem
das auf so eine ähnliche richtung
hinweis und benannten immer bei einem in
villigen regress diesem ständigen ist
sich selbst erklären
ok und jetzt ist alles total das hat
sich eine ganzen gedanken macht es geht
ins unendliche
weil wir immer belegt ist mit bewegtem
erklären würden
und er nennt diesen unbelegten beweger
bezahlt bezeichnet derweil nur so kann
es viele strukturelle funktionieren war
so die der gedanke dahinter ja jetzt ist
aber jetzt wenn meine frage befasst
starten anfang hatte ich noch mal eine
andere sichtweise wie die physik was
macht damit um also die physik sagt dass
überhaupt nur was passiert wenn es einen
unterschied gibt also wenn alles gleich
es kann nichts passieren man braucht
immer eine differenz und diese differenz
kann würde man in der physik als eine
rein zufälliger fluktuation von energie
würde man das annehmen also wir wissen
wenn es also annahme dass universum war
schon immer ein quanten physikalisches
das heißt im allerkleinsten sobald man
die skalen von dem atom erreicht oder
einem atomkern also noch kleiner wird 10
- 15 meter und noch kleine dann ist man
immer in der welt der quantenmechanik in
der quantenmechanik sind alle größen um
dieses berühmte wirkungs quantum herum
fluktuierend es gibt keine genauigkeit
die unterhalb dieser größe ist und damit
sind schwankungen von dieser größe immer
mehr
und daraus ließe sich im prinzip durch
lang kein zufall
ein universum konstruieren das dann
tatsächlich praktisch über ja wie soll
ich sagen über über das ziel
hinausschießt und in einen zustand gerät
den man dann als so genanntes falsches
vakuum bezeichnet das aber schon mit ein
physikalischer ausdruck philosophisch
gesprochen würde ich mich hier an
nikolaus von kues orientieren dem
cusanus ja koinzidenz der opposition
und ich brauche einen unterschiedlich
brauche eine irgend eine differenz die
es mir möglich macht diesen anfang von
dem nicht anfangen zu unterscheiden und
am anfang muss alles zusammen fall und
doch muss es einen unterschied geben
weil ohne diesen anfangen also ohne
diesen unterschied gar nichts möglich
sind das interessante ist dass ich das
eben in der physik auch tatsächlich
zeigen lässt also wenn alles gleich ist
alles im gleichgewicht ist dann gibt es
überhaupt keine keine bewegung für
aristoteles ist natürlich so der hat
eine andere bewegungs theorie weil der
immer ein bewegter brauchte damit die
dinge sich bewegen in der physik ist es
so es wirkt dann eine kraft wenn sich
die geschwindigkeit verändert ansonsten
bewegt sich der körper immer mit
gleicher geschwindigkeit gleichförmig
aristoteles bräuchte aber für die
gleichen geschwindigkeit schon an bewege
sich nun heraus und geht die versuchten
davon aus dass so ein geschlossenes
system in sich ein unterschied hat oder
kann sie auch sagen das system was
irgendwie auf nun rausgehen habt einen
unterschied in dem zweiten aus
das ist ja bei uns dass es technisch und
damit empirisch nicht mit nicht mehr zur
verfügung steht können wir das nicht
sagen sie können also wir können wir
können praktisch immer nur eigenschaft
innere eigenschaften des gesamten
universums formulieren
wir können keine äußeren eigenschaften
formulieren weil wir uns nur mit den
strukturen beschäftigen die innerhalb
des kosmos da sind und selbst die
philosophie wird es schwierig ohne
bestimmte grundlegende prinzipien der
der erkenntnisgewinnung zu verletzen
sich mit dem kosmos als ganzen zu
bestellen ist ja erst mal schon mal die
frage kann man sich überhaupt mit dem
kosmos als ganzen beschäftigen rein
wissenschafts theoretisch ist die
physiker eine wissenschaft die sich auf
reproduzierbare ergebnisse stützt
bei dem kosmos haben wir es aber mit
einem historischen ablauf zu tun
die offenbar genau ein einziges mal war
also das heißt wir haben hier gar nichts
was wir so ohne weiteres reproduzieren
können weil wir keine verschiedenen
universen haben jetzt sagen wo man sagen
können dass eine entwickelt sich so dass
andere es so wir können keine statistik
waren wir nur den einzelfall
wir haben keine erfahrung damit und
damit ergibt sich natürlich eine ganz
alte philosophische frage wie ist das
verhältnis von allgemeinen und
besonderen wenn aber das besondere das
einzige ist was wir haben also der
einzige der einzige fall ist den wir
haben
dann wird es halt schwierig darüber dass
vernünftiges aus zu sagen so geht es
beim leben ja auch also wir kennen nur
einen planeten von von dem wir wissen da
gibt es leben wenn wir vielleicht in gar
nicht so ferner zukunft mal andere
planeten entdecken werden muss leben
gibt dann können wir überleben ganz neu
nachdenken auch philosophisch neu
nachdenken aber so bis dahin sind wir
immer eingeschränkt gerade auch was
stichwort henne ei auch das leben ist so
ein phänomen wo man wo man sagt naja
offenbar müssen die bedingungen sowohl
die inneren wie die äußeren bedingungen
so gewesen sein dass materie beginnt
sich nach einer weile so zu
strukturieren dass auf einmal eine
eigenschaft auftaucht die vorher gar
nicht da war nämlich die eigenschaft
dass eine chemische verbindung ihrer
umgebung so manipuliert hat das für die
entstehung dieser ursprünglich
chemischen verbindung alles optimal ist
das heißt es entsteht immer mehr immer
mehr und das nimmt man molekulare
evolution das ist aber noch lange weit
davon entfernt das leben ist und beim
universum ist es natürlich auch so wir
können alle diese diese
selbstreferentiellen fragen stellen wo
das universum sich nach sich selber vor
und je nachdem wie wir beginnen landen
wir bei ganz unterschiedlichen
kosmologischen modellen
es hilft aber da auch wieder das ist
fast immer so es hilft immer kurt gödel
das ist auch an dieser großen
hilfreichen denker nämlich den hat man
ja gestern ja und ist als derjenige sagt
jede art von aussagen system wie mächtig
ist auch immer sie enthält mindestens
eine aussage die selbst nicht begründen
kann dieser unvollständigkeit beweis der
liefert dir ganz automatisch die
möglichkeit die ich mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen ohne dass du dich immer
wieder in dem kreis drehst weil
irgendwann kommt und sagt jetzt reicht's
aber du weißt genau dass man irgendwas
automatisch anfangen muss und das ist
natürlich auch ganz wichtig bei dem
stichwort triumph der physik dass
nämlich das wird glaube ich oft
unterschätzt wie wichtig diese
automatische ansatz ist das ist so und
so wenn wenn wenn da machen wir
schlussfolgerungen und bei uns wird die
schlussfolgerungen aber nicht gezogen in
form von interpretationen sondern die
schlussfolgerung zieht das experiment
das experiment stellt dann fest ob die
reihe von wenn wenn wenn uns die
schlussfolgerung liefert die man
theoretischer gibt oder aber ist es
nicht der fall das heißt das experiment
ist eine externe institution die nicht
mehr mit irgendwie der rationalität der
beteiligten personen zu tun hat sondern
nur noch das ist ein externer externe
institution und die entscheidet jetzt
darüber so also wenn du zum gericht
gehst ja richter entscheidet wir
streiten uns hier entscheide du mal und
das ist der große vorteil
das ist praktisch der der ganz große
sprung für die für die
erkenntnisgewinnung auch das jetzt auf
einmal dieser dieser äußere partner da
ist also wie ich selber gerne ihr spiel
mit der bande also wir wenn wir wenn wir
erkenntnis billard spielen in der physik
dann schießen wir eine kugel los zu der
bande und dann hoffen wir dass die kugel
auf der anderen seite so genau dahin
kommt wo wir ihn haben wollen indem wir
nämlich prognosen und vorhersagen machen
die genau das machen was sie oder die
die hoffentlich bestätigung finden wenn
nicht dann ist die theorie tod und so um
dass man sozusagen sind wir natürlich
auch bei der kosmologie vorgegangen also
die reine die reine idee ist hätte ein
anfang gegeben oder so das hätte in der
physiker freien fall überzeugt sondern
erst die bestätigung der vorhersagen
dieser idee dass die welt mindestens mal
so klein gewesen um den atomkern und das
sich aus den erkenntnissen der
kernphysik im labor lässt sich dann auf
allgemeine eigenschaften des gesamten
universum schließen
als es so klein war wie ein atomkern das
ist ja eine ihre situation über sich
überlegt diese lebewesen in dem
universum die haben einen kognitiven
apparate oben von anderthalb kilo und
ich sagen moment mal das was wir da
wissen das muss ja überall im universum
gültig sein
das könnte sogar für das ganze universum
gültig sein da habe ich überhaupt keine
gedanken darüber gemacht was das
eigentlich die erkenntnis theoretisch
wären für ein hammer ist ja später hat
man angefangen männlich philosophie der
kosmologie der tat aber diejenigen die
damals diese ganz kurzen artikel in der
zeitschrift nature publiziert haben also
alpha gamauf in 1948 das sind relativ
easy going paper jeder student im
zweiten semester physik versteht da
sofort unter denkbar ist so stark war ja
genau um das vielleicht ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen ist können wir
eigentlich sagen ich nehme mich da auf
stephen hawking kurze geschichte der
zeit
die physik kann alles ab dem urknall
irgendwie erklären oder wenn ich will
nicht alles sagen aber nie befasst sich
halt damit wo sie sich um ihr ausfällt
vielleicht stimmt das jetzt nicht aber
das team morgen gesagt wo sie sich
aufhält ist die frage vor dem urknall
der ist es sozusagen problematisch
können wir nicht sagen dazu werden wir
können keine messungen vornehmen und
wenn wir genau dieses spiel nicht
spielen können wenn wir einen strich
drunter schlussfolgerung ziehen ausland
experiment wenn es jetzt irgend einer
theorie geben die sagen würde wenn es
ein paralleluniversum geben soll dann
muss es bei uns so seien und dass eben
auch konsequent nachweisen könnte dann
wäre natürlich was dann wäre etwas
anderes dann könnte man sagen na ja also
wenn die annahmen stimmen sollten dann
würden wir aus der eigenschaft unseres
universums auf die existenz eines
paralleluniversum schließen nur ich kann
mir keine vorstellen also die man da
irgendwie nachweisen können soll ja ja
ja ja ich meine letzten endes darf man
nicht vergessen es nichts haben mehr
attraktivität als erfolg und wenn man
sich jetzt mal anschaut wie die
geschichte unseres universums offenbar
abgelaufen ist wie viele von den
vorhersagen wer innerhalb der astronomie
vor allen dingen eben am himmel
bestätigt finden wir haben wir dann eben
auch den überbringer der guten nachricht
nämlich die elektromagnetische strahlung
diese dessen eigenschaften sind uns aber
auch gut bekannt aus dem labor
das heißt wir finden also dieses wie
soll ich sagen dass intellektuelle
wechselspiel zwischen den irdischen für
sicht betreibenden und dehnen und dem
universum ist halt deshalb unglaublich
intensiv und gleichzeitig eben sehr sehr
erfolgreich weil ständig wird irgendeine
dieser theorien bestätigt man kann das
auf den punkt bringen zum beispiel die
spezielle relativitätstheorie von
einstein beschäftigt sich mit bewegungen
in der nähe der lichtgeschwindigkeit das
zeigt sich aber dass zb die entstehung
eines magnetfeldes durch den
elektrischen strom
er hat mir in der schule gelernt wenn
der strom durch den daumen geht geht das
magnetfeld die finger usw
die also die ein magnetfeld ist
überhaupt nur zu verstehen mit hilfe der
relativitätstheorie der speziellen
relativitätstheorie wurde
wenn man das jedes mal wenn in diesem
universum irgendwo ein transformator ein
magnetfeld induziert kann der einstein
sagen ja srz das heißt damit wird
bestätigt dass die lichtgeschwindigkeit
die maximale wirkung
transportgeschwindigkeit ist und so
weiter und so weiter
also das heißt mit anderen worten der
erfolg dieser methodik es halt so
durchgreifend das heißt wir versuchen es
auf möglichst viel anzuwenden wo wir
phänomene in reiner form finden und das
tollste am universum ist es fast leer
das heißt man hat so gut wie keine
reibung dort man kann die bewegung am
himmel unglaublich gut vorausberechnen
und das war ja nun auch
geistesgeschichte ich der große wurf
dass durch diese prognosefähigkeit der
himmelsmechanik man auf einmal gedacht
hat na ja meine himmel berechnen können
das noch mal alles berichten
und das ist natürlich eine geschichte
gewesen die ein tiefes missverständnis
darstellt weil das universum ist ein
ideales system fasst es gibt keinerlei
störung also deswegen können die
planeten sich ja auch schon so lange um
die sonne herum bewegen ohne dass ihre
baden gestört werden weil da draußen
nichts ist was rein wie ich immer sage
das kann jeder feststellen der abend in
den himmel guckt wenn wir sterne sehen
dann kann zwischen unserem auge und dem
stern nix sein was das nicht verschluckt
so würde ich das nicht sehen
also das heißt da gibt es eine ganze
reihe von so korrespondenz prinzipien
und in der wissenschaftstheorie kann man
sich dann angucken wodurch eigentlich
die stärke dieser empirischen forschung
möglichkeit und diese empfehlung social
dieser empirischen forschungsmethode
endlich besteht
und dann kann man gucken kann man diese
art von empirischer forschung woanders
anwenden
und wenn du sagst wir könnten alles
erklären weit gefehlt sobald sie nämlich
zu komplex wird hier sind wir raus ja
mit unseren schönen naturgesetzen weil
dann nämlich zusätzlich zu den gesetzen
noch etwas dazu kommt dass ein völlig
anderen ontologischen status hat und
kaum ein physiker würde würde darauf
würde da würde das so sagen nämlich auf
der einen seite haben wir die gesetze
aber der ontologischen status von von
anfang so ein randbedingungen ist ja der
kontingenz die können auch ganz anders
sein
sie sind also nicht notwendig für die
gesetze die sind notwendig aber die
bedingungen können irgendwie sein
das heißt da gibt es da gibt es eine
mischung von von notwendig um kontingent
und das ist er das ist eigentlich die
pforte dass durch diese mischung
entstehen auf einmal phänomene die
überhaupt nicht mehr definiert sind in
keiner weise definiert sind wären lebens
mechanik die ist ja wirklich das ist
eine maschine laster dämon sage mir alle
geschwindigkeiten und alle orte aller
teilchen nicht rekonstruieren die
vergangenheit und sage die die zukunft
solange nur die jüdische mechanik
existiert ok ja ich bin erstaunt darüber
wie flüssig die übergänge laufen gerade
weil die frage nach feiert und
determinismus gestellt sind physiker von
grund auf
er ist sein haben die signatur
determinismus dass sie sagen wenn die
physischen gesetze deterministisch sind
dann muss ist auch unsere freiheit
dementsprechend eingeschränkt oder
welche also ich würde immer sagen dass
wir im enorm großen freiheits raum haben
und zwar durch diese nicht notwendigen
anfangs und randbedingungen damit wird
die tür aufgemacht zu einem nicht
deterministischen universum
ich hab da gesetze drin das keine frage
aber die mischung mit den kontingenten
bedingungen löst alles auflöst die der
terminierung natürlich auf das ist schon
im allerkleinsten sodass man sieht zum
beispiel warum wächst denn entropie eine
aussage über die möglichkeitsform die
ein system hat obwohl doch mikroskopisch
ist doch alles reversibel vorwärts
rückwärts alles gleich bedeutend aber
als alles gleich möglich und trotzdem
bei jedem vorgang den wir haben egal wie
sehr ihn auch immer beeinflussen immer
verlieren wir energie immer verlieren
wir bei den prozessen informationen und
woran liegt das das liegt eben daran
weil immer pausenlos irgendwelche
kleinen störungen kleine variationen von
irgendwas auftauchen die energie aus dem
system heraus nehmen und das ist der
grund dafür dass es hat dieses universum
ins gesamten zeit fallen hat dass wir
niemals an einen alten zeitpunkt
zurückkommen können wir können zweimal
den gleichen ort aber niemals zweimal in
die gleiche zeit das heißt wir haben
eine qualitative zeit dimension eine
quantitative raumdimensionen und all
diese dinge laufen darauf hinaus auch
gerade in der debatte zum beispiel über
die philosophie des geistes gibt es ja
das berühmte viread dilemma
und da gibt es diese aussage die
weltzeit kausal geschlossen kein
physiker würde jemals sagen dass die
welt geschlossen ist das kann man
überhaupt
naja das ist ein unterschied also da
muss man sich irgendwie klar machen wie
man die mentalen eigenschaften definiert
wenn also die mentalen eigenschaften und
die physikalischen eigenschaften wie
sind die überhaupt verbunden
dann hätten wir dann wäre es am ende so
dass man eigentlich ableiten müsste aus
dem material aus diesen materiellen
eigenschaften dass wir keinen freien
willen
aber in dem moment wo man erst beim
ersten mal klar wird und es gibt sind
ein großartiges buch von brigitte
falkenburg mythos determinismus wo sie
sagt unser gehirn ist kein computer
unser gehirn ist eine dampfmaschine der
80 prozent der zeit der 80 prozent der
energie in unserem hirn werden verwendet
damit es schön warm ist thermodynamische
ist das klar wärme bedeutet ich kann
entropie exportieren und kann diesen
ordnungs zustand meiner neuron eines
neuronalen meiner neuronale vernetzung
dort oben aufrechterhalten
aber das bedeutet vor allen dingen eine
pausenlose höchst komplexe wirklich
komplexe nicht nur kompliziert sondern
komplexe vernetzung von von
prozessketten und das ist erst mal das
was praktisch wenn also materiell meine
bewusstsein unterliegt aber ich bin weit
davon entfernt
daraus irgendetwas ableiten zu können
wie diese personen sich im nächsten
moment verhält ich kann statistiken
waren verhaltensforschung und so weiter
ich kann mentale zustände beschreiben
und so weiter aber der entscheidende
punkt ist doch was es bedeutet marcel zu
sein weiß nur du weil wenn ich jetzt
dein gehirn tatsächlich ups kenne mache
ich nur einen schnappschuss
aber ich müsste eigentlich ein film
drehen ich müsste eigentlich dein leben
das was dein gehirn erlebt hat wie es
die gedächtnisinhalte pausenlos umgebaut
hat neu korreliert hat das ist doch
nicht nur ein bild oder zehn bilder
das ist doch das gesamte leben was du
vorher geführt dass das heißt da sind
wir wieder bei den anfangs und
randbedingungen das was davor war spielt
eine wichtige rolle für das was jetzt
ist und unsere freiheit räume sind gehen
in die zukunft die gehen nicht in die
vergangenheit die vergangenheit ist
ökologischer auf einen anderen zustand
als die zukunft und deswegen ist
freiheit immer etwas was mit den räumen
zu tun hat die wir schon hinter uns
haben der umgebung mit der wir gerade
wechseln würden
und das ist alles andere als
determiniert also verstehe ich gar nicht
warum man darauf kommen kann
genau also das was wir gerade geführt
haben davor hat man gesprochen das
vielleicht so zu sagen es gibt diese
sichtweise ist eine sichtweise der
physik das zeit natürlich erst mal aktiv
ist und gegenwart zukunft vergangenheit
eigentlich eine ähnliche ausstellung
haben wir das bedeutet die sind gleich
wirklich noch der bahnreise wirkliche
also sozusagen die vergangenheit ist
genauso wirklich jetzt und auch die
zukunft hier
das würde ja der sicht weil sie gerade
so ein bisschen widersprechen nur
bisschen über das alter des 190 medien
aber genau also da hinten dann in dieser
form könnte man sich hinterfragen was
ihr also das ist ja würde ich auch als
als errungenschaft der musik bezeichnen
dass man dort auf so eine idee kommt hey
vielleicht haben wir gar keine klare
linien der das recht ist alles so ein
bisschen gleichzeitig und da haben wir
also in der physik eine errungenschaft
und die philosophie eine integration auf
die philosophie weil wenn das alles
gleichzeitig werden ist ja moral also
die frage nach dem wollen eine ganz
andere oder also aber das ist eben das
ist ein richtiges missverständnis in den
gleichungen der physik taucht die zeit
tatsächlich als ein parameter auf den
man auch immer wieder auf null stellen
kann
immer wieder immer wieder ganzen
versuche immer wir dann vorne mal also
das wäre dann eine anfangs bedingung die
im rahmen eines experiments festgelegtes
das ist so und mache ich neue oder in
der relativitätstheorie ist die zeit
immer eine uhrzeit das heißt es muss
mindestens zwei uhren geben die
miteinander verglichen werden können
wunderbar schön aber da ist sie ist
damit passiv in der wirklichkeit
allerdings macht es einen großen
unterschied ob wir das interview jetzt
führen oder ob wir schon vor fünf tagen
geführt hätten
dann würden wir beide jetzt hier schon
ein ganz anderes interview führen weil
das andere gespräch war schon da das
heißt ich muss nur noch mal darauf
hinweisen die rolle dieser anfangs und
randbedingungen ändert die gesamte
struktur der welt das was wir jetzt tun
machen wir jetzt und dann nie wieder
und selbst wenn wir jetzt uns genauso
hinsetzen würden wir beide hätten uns
verändert werden alles wäre in diesem
raum auf einen quandt mechanisch
grundlegenden ebene wäre völlig anders
ja das heißt man kann nicht einfach so
das überspringen
dass die welt während man über sie
nachdenkt sich schon verändert
also das ist natürlich eine
metaphysische fragestellungen wir also
was ist der otto logische status von
dimensionen aber die zeit ist für mich
etwas gerade deshalb weil wir in der
physik dass wir die unentwegt bestätigt
finden ist eine qualitative dimension
und die ist was völlig anderes als der
raum und man kann nicht so tun als
bliebe man im raum die zeit wäre mehr
oder weniger auch nur so eine konstante
wie eben die dimensionierung des raumes
sondern die zeit ist etwas ganz
besonderes weil sie ständig von den
veränderungen sie seien ein maß für die
veränderungen die mit uns stattfinden
die mit der welt stattfinden die aber
zugleich die voraussetzungen auch da
stellen wir das was demnächst passieren
kann ja wurde das ist der terminiert ist
aber der möglichkeitsraum wird dadurch
aufgespannt durch das was passiert ist
ja das ist mir sehr einleuchtend als ihm
gefällt jetzt noch einen punkt ein
die nicht dagegen halten würde nämlich
es könnte ja das doch sein dass die zeit
ein einmal von sagt man so einen traum
und dann könnte man sagen aus dieser
ausgesuchten perspektive ist zeit etwas
das gibt es gar nicht so wie wir es
wahrnehmen sondern das eben gegenzug
unvergessen sind ausgesucht wer weiter
aber es geht aber für subjektive
perspektive ist weiterhin einfach ich
habe mehr erfahren das ist ja eine
erfahrung also die lebenserfahrung das
kann ich euch nur sagen also oder dir
nur sagen ich bin ja ich werde nächstes
jahr 60 und ich war schon anders
ja klar es ist da war also ich war mal
anders in keine frage und das heißt
gerade diese dieser punkt mit der
lebenserfahrung das ist so
das ist so ein punkt wo ich glaube wo
man in der philosophie viel intensiver
darüber nachdenken muss
die verehrung der physik als der ideal
wissenschaft dem idealen empirischen
wissenschaft überhaupt
sie beschäftigt sich mit einfachen
systemen und die der ganze kritischen
rationalismus popper kann man da runter
beten und kuhn mit seinen paradigma und
soweit alles großartig aber es gibt eine
erfahrung die für das
für die sind nur wie es persönlich
messinstrumente und dass unsere
lebenserfahrung wir erfahren unser leben
niemand sonst erfährt unser leben nur
wir die anderen sind manchmal dabei
manchmal ist man allein mann hat seine
eigenen albträume und so weiter und so
weiter
also das heißt was es bedeutet sich zu
sein
ich selbst weiß nur mein selbst und ich
kann darüber reden ich kann versuchen
das irgendwie darzustellen um mich
auszudrücken
und wenn man sich anschaut was dass
menschen für ausdrucksformen gefunden
haben über ihre ängste ihre hoffnung
vision über liebe und so weiter dann
sieht man dass da eine unglaubliche
bandbreite da ist und zugleich aber kann
man natürlich feststellen ob oma da der
eine denkt so der andere denkt der hat
sein leben so erfahren aber die hatten
alle eine leber milz nähere gehirn zwei
augen zwar funktionierte oder barbara
barbara bach so gleiche ausstattung
völlig unterschiedliche
lebenserfahrungen völlig und das
bedeutet eine erfahrungswissen schafft
und das sind empirische wissenschaften
entzieht sich die wichtigste erfahrung
die wir vom leben überhaupt machen
können nämlich unsere lebenserfahrung
die können die kann niemand messen nur
wir tun das leben ist nachgerade das
messen einer solchen erfahrung strecke
und das gehört ja mit dazu wenn man also
ein metaphysisches in metaphysischen
entwurf um die welt macht kann man nicht
nur das so tun als ginge es hier nur um
diese so genannten objektiven
eigenschaften die von völlig objektiven
messinstrumenten vorgenommen werden
sondern wir ja auch sondern wir haben
ziele zwecke auf einmal beginnt eine
metaphysik zu leben weil die hoffnungen
visionen und träume von von personen in
dieser welt ebenfalls einen
ontologischen status haben man kann ihn
nicht so einfach weg das ist irgendwie
sind bio management überbau nein sondern
die haben ja auch kausale wirkung
dadurch dass wir diese ziele und zwecke
verfolgen das heißt wir sind in der welt
und diesen dass das ist eine ganz ich
halte das für für ein riesendefizit wenn
wir wenn wir nicht immer wieder darüber
reden können bei den metaphysischen
entwürfen dass es da menschen dass da
menschen drin sind und dass die
natürlich einen teil dieses
mit der physischen welt bis sein müssen
mit mit allem was dazugehört und da sind
wir aber automatisch bei der metaphysik
von freiheit weil offensichtlich sich
die materie im laufe der jahrmilliarden
in diesem universum strukturiert
strukturiert strukturiert und dann auf
einmal taucht mindestens einmal wer weiß
wie oft noch überall im universum
tauchen lebewesen auf die aufgrund ihrer
inneren dispositionen freiheits räume
haben die kein anderes lebewesen vorher
jemals hatte
und vielleicht gibt es ja noch ganz
andere möglichkeiten von freiheit zu
denken aber wir haben sie und das
interessante resultat ist dass diese
empirischen wissenschaften den letzten
25 jahren angefangen haben und gesagt
haben du hast kein freiheit zu haben
wie kann man das behaupten ohne den
freiheits raum zu besitzen anderen die
freiheits raum zu bestreiten ja also da
gibt es ja eine reihe von widersprüchen
thomas nation hat darauf hingewiesen wie
wäre es eine fledermaus zu sein und dann
diese positionen die man eigentlich gar
nicht einnehmen kann und so weiter und
so weiter
das heißt also hier bisschen vorsicht
hier zu sein und das noch mal von der
anderen viel viel ja vielleicht auch
theoretischen ebene aus anzuschauen
das halte ich für ganz wichtig gerade im
hinblick darauf bevor man uns die
freiheit abspricht und man sagt du
kannst machen was du willst du bist
sowieso nicht frei du bist und bis gar
nicht mündig da sollte man doch sehr
positiv sein mit dem was ja super also
in sagen wir in diesem ganzen gespräch
drei große themen angesprochen also drei
konkrete fragen besprochen zum thema
ganzen möglichkeiten der philosophie und
physik und das war zum einen die opal
frage die nach ursprung freiheit und
moral fertig sozusagen zum schluss für
dich noch eine eine andere frage was sie
nämlich von übernatürlichen halten das
natürlich das allererste wie definiert
man lässt sich an ihren ideen freien die
ehre ganz viel spielraum gebotenen wie
man wie man übernatürliches definiert
und dann ergibt es oder eben nicht
naturalisten ist es immer so es geht in
der welt mit rechten dingen zu das heißt
alles was passiert muss ich irgendwie
mindestens anders an
anpassen lassen was wir schon kennen
zumal eben die kenntnis von
verschiedenen natürlichen vorgängen
inzwischen so präzise ist das ist eine
ganz harte nummer wird da was einzubauen
was den total widersprechen würde dann
müsste man sagen er hatte gibt es
offenbar einige sätze struktur die über
dem ganzen licht und die uns zumindest
in einer bestimmten variation vorgaukelt
hier wird etwas übernatürliches passiert
aber was soll das sein über natur also
wenn das universum alles ist was da ist
dann ist alles was im universum passiert
natürlich sogar das was wir als
menschlicher aktivität bezeichnet könnte
man ja sagen der mensch teil der natur
also dann ist da alles was er tut auch
natürlich selbst die technologischen
katastrophen sie anrichten die
kunststoffe die es ohne ihn nie gegeben
hätte unsere antwort
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem so dass
man immer wieder überrascht ist wie groß
eigentlich die bandbreite von einem
bestimmten phänomen ist es gibt ja in
der physik den oder der mathematik zum
ausdruck der normalverteilung also was
ist denn der normalfall
und dann gibt es aber hinten wie mein
freund gunkel österreichische
kabarettist immer sagt in der nord- ost-
kurve der gaußsche normalverteilung da
hinten da wo die exponential funktion
eigentlich schon fast null ist
da gibt es dann doch noch mal den einen
oder anderen fall und das ist
überraschend
das ist passiert aber in komplexen
systemen ist man von keiner überraschung
sicher das heißt also gerade dann wenn
systeme sehr empfindlich werden
gegenüber kleinen störungen und das ist
eben der große unterschied zwischen der
vorstellung man hätte so eine ganz
starke kausalität in der welt das würde
bedeuten ähnliche ursachen produzieren
ähnliche wirkungen das heißt ich hätte
so einen ganz klaren strahl selbst wenn
ich jetzt die ursachen so ein bisschen
ändere die wirkungen bleiben in einem
ähnlichen bereich aber in dem komplexen
system ist es so dass ähnliche ursachen
völlig unterschiedliche wirkungen haben
das heißt kleine veränderungen meiner
ursachen situation und butch das system
läuft wohl ganz anders hin
aber solange wir natürlich in dieser
starken kausalität denken ist jede
abweichung und dieser starken qualität
für uns an normal um nicht zu sagen über
natürlich das heißt wenn wir uns mal
drauf einlassen und grundsätzlich dass
systeme die komplex sind überraschungen
bieten dann sind diese überraschung erst
mal auf jeden fall nicht mehr für die
konstitution einer wissenschaft
irgendwie gefährlich sondern das aber
interessant
sie haben wir wieder ein phänomen das
wir vorher nicht kann und ich kann an
dieser stelle nur hannah arendt zitieren
die gesagt hat wenn menschen
zusammenkommen muss man davon ausgehen
dass wunder geschehen und das ist halt
immer möglich das heißt diese art von
überraschungen sollten wir uns auch
nicht auf keinen fall nehmen das meter
von der physiker von der philosophie
danke danke dafür dass filme sehr
wichtige unterstützung für das ganze ja
wir sehen uns bei einem nächsten folge
von 4cast ich hoffe das hat spaß gemacht
ihr könnt gerne eure kommentare und
gedanken unter dem video lassen und
vielleicht bis zum nächsten mal
das ist okay meta ebene so zu sagen dass
ich an interessieren welche bedeutung
das ist folgerichtig dass er sich selbst
im internet an sie medienträchtigen